Welcome back everyone big surprise marvel just
dropped a brand new first look at thor 11 thunders
we'll break it all down the brand new scene
features boss the panther goddess which is our
big connection to black panther 2 and what just
happened on moon knight obviously part of the gorr
the god butcher storyline going around killing all
the mcu gods i know there's a bunch of questions
about what's going on with her and how this is
tied to black panther too so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos the really big
thing you probably saw in your feeds today is that
marvel released a new thor loving thunder scene
that comes directly from the movie's website it
features valkyrie jane foster in her mighty thor
armor valkyrie is obviously in her brand new armor
too embossed the panther goddess in the middle of
what looks like a meeting of all the mcu gods who
have a war cancel about what to do about gord the
god butcher there was a scene about her history
in the first black panther movie explaining how
she became the god of the panther tribe in the
first place a warrior shaman received a vision
from the panther goddess bust who led him to the
heart shaped earth you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered consciousness
exist like the ancestral plane oh just gorgeous
like they say they even legit mention the
ancestral plane from wakanda as an alternate
dimension that their people just travel to based
on their beliefs inside the multiverse the big
connection to moonite is that boss is actually
part of the same pantheon that khonshu comes from
that's why it looks like she's dressed in egyptian
garb she's actually khonshu's biological sister
that's right gods can have children just like
normal people that was why odin was able to
have thor and thor was able to be born a god
inside the mcu conscious boss's father is the
leader of that mcu-annie pantheon of gods so even
though she is conscious sister or member of their
pantheon their people believe different things
so the version of the afterlife that they go to
after they die their soul basically separates from
their physical body their consciousness it goes to
a completely different dimension even though
like i said she is part of the same pantheon
thor would also be part of this meeting too
because obviously it's after gorr the god
butcher has attacked so he'd be sitting in another
part of this room while these gods are all meeting
with each other and he knows who all the other
mcu gods are he'd know zeus he'd know boss all the
other members of the idiot so like for instance
thor would know who khonshu is but to charge some
of the timeline thor basically finds out what's
going on with gord the god butcher this scene is
actually directly out of the comics this is one of
gorr's victims it's another god that's a friend of
thor so he's really sad seeing that his friend has
died it just happens to be a really giant creature
when he starts seeing gorr's path of destruction
that's what brings him back to new asgard and he
comes back as gorr's attacking and it just
seems like the order of events is they have
that funny fake play with the matt damon version
of loki and they have the luke hemsworth chris
hemsworth's brother playing the fake version of
thor in the melissa mccarthy version of hella
doing just that funny twist on thor ragnarok and
the destruction of the hammer it seems like jane
foster just happens to be near the pieces of
mjolnir and touching them when he's attacking
when they actually do need the power of thor and
the enchantment is just strong enough like hella
didn't break the enchantment it brings the hammer
back together and gives her all of her female thor
armor so he's completely flabbergasted by that
but then they have this meeting of the godhead
where all the gods that would care about what
happens on earth are meeting to talk about what's
happening with gorr the god butcher the similarity
between bast and khonshu is that they're both
viewed as kind of rogues within their pantheon
like she's not a member of the mcu versus the any
of their ruling council but she's been a member
of the comic book version in the past the other
gods that are part of their pantheon don't like
them quite as much because of some of the things
they've done in the past in the hand that they've
taken in the role of the people who worship them
so for instance khonshu kind of hates them and
they kind of hate khonshu because khonshu thinks
that they never should have left earth and gone
to this pocket dimension he goes around trying to
visit his justice using his avatar's moon knight
during the black panther flashback when they talk
about her giving this advice to the wakandans
leading them to the heart-shaped herb and helping
them gain powers and gain this really spiritual
connection with her forming a contract with her
that granted him superhuman strength speed and
instincts the warrior became king and the first
black panther when the rest of their pantheon left
to go to this pocket dimension she kind of did the
same thing that khonshu did like she continued to
help her people help black panther and the rest
of the wakandans which is why their other gods
don't like her that much either but this is our
big connection between everything that happened on
moon knight everything that's happening with gorr
the god butcher going around killing all the mcu
gods in thor love and thunder like it's a version
of end game but for the gods and everything that's
happening in black panther 2 sort of setting that
movie up because it is literally the next big mcu
movie after thor love and thunder most of black
panther's supernatural powers come from her in the
comics like he gets a lot of his physical powers
from the heart-shaped herb but he has the ability
to draw on the experience of every previous black
panther going back in history they call him king
of the dead some of those spiritual powers he
gains the same way that moon knight gains powers
that layla gain powers from their respective gods
the difference with black panther though is
that he's not literally the avatar of bast
as you can see this woman wearing traditional
egyptian garb that looks kind of inspired by
wakandan but obviously it's the other way
around wakandan's inspired by her appearance
even though she's a part of conscious pantheon
big part of this story the reason why you didn't
see her during moon knight episodes is because
literally they were in the middle of using her
during thor love and thunder as part of this
gorr storyline it's the exact same reason that
namor wasn't on the 838 illuminati in doctor
strange too even though he was a core member
of the team in the comics the writer said they
were already using him in black panther too so
even if it seems weird that they don't include
some characters in important crossover scenes
like why is an xyz character here it's usually
because some other movie is using that character
there was even a deleted scene for gorr the
god butcher during the moon knight finale
they were going to start talking about gor
the god but you're going around killing all
the mcu gods because they're literally hiding
out in this pocket dimension so they're only
safe from gorr for a very brief period eventually
gorr would become powerful enough to traverse the
multiverse and start killing all the gods of other
universes too that's why thor love and thunder is
like endgame for the gods and not just the gods
of the mcu the guys of the entire multiverse
r.i.p reality for those of you asking when this
scene takes place though jane foster because she
has her mighty thor armor she has a version of
the hammer already it's after gorr's attack new
asgard and threatened the earth which ropes
in what's going on with all these other god's
congregations that's why all the other gods like
boss for example would care about this oh we're
all being killed we're being targeted that means
i'm next on his list we need to worry about this
the reason why doctor strange doesn't step in
to help them here is because what's happening
during this movie is taking place around the same
time that things are going crazy in doctor strange
too so he's busy with the multiverse and dealing
with scarlet witch while this is all going down
similar problem different day just the end of
all reality no big deal for those of you that
were hoping that they would do a version of
the godhead in the mcu because they didn't do
one during avengers infinity war and avengers end
game this is basically them doing that the godhead
is a big thing during the comic book version
of avengers infinity war the thanos infinity
gauntlet storyline all the different gods of the
616 universe which we now know is canonically
the main mcu universe thank you very much doctor
strange too for canonizing the main mcu is 616.
odin holds a meeting of all the most powerful gods
in the universe to decide what to do about thanos
and stop him from assembling all the infinity
stones in that version of events thanos winds up
stopping them by basically destroying the rainbow
bridge because the comic book version of asgard
existed the same way that khonshu's pantheon
exists in moon knight like they're all inside
this pocket dimension in the comics asgard is in
a pocket dimension and you need the rainbow bridge
to tunnel through dimensions in order to get to
it the mcu version is a little bit different it
is meant to be like an other planet you could
actually fly to the architecture in this room
seems like old school north so it seems like this
scene is happening somewhere around new asgard
but most of the gods that you would actually see
in this scene here like it's only part of the
scene that we're seeing the rest of the gods would
just have deep ties to earth like zeus and the
other greek gods that you see during the trailer
they'd have deep ties to earth as well just like
the asgardians if they do actually swerve on this
and say that this is literally boss like it's not
her avatar they could say that this is just a
place of power that allows her to project her
image here but for those of you asking what the
rules about gods being in the mcu are like some
gods are walking around normally like thor and
some gods are trapped in a pocket dimension and
can only appear in people's minds like khonshu for
example one of the reasons behind that is that all
the different gods have vastly different power
levels like not all gods are created equal the
ones that are more powerful tend to have a more
hands-off role and this also ties in with gorr
the god butcher's mission to kill them all most of
them don't want to interfere with their subjects
that much so a lot of the gods have traveled to
other realms in different dimensions outside the
main mcu some of the lesser gods like thor are
able to do whatever they want to in the mcu as
long as they don't go completely off the rails
it's a really good example why odin for example
didn't cause a giant god tier end game when he
was conquering the nine realms if he'd continued
trying to conquer the rest of the galaxy the rest
of the universe the other gods would have risen
up against him and that would have basically led
to another avengers endgame situation destroying
all of the multiverse with like every single god
everywhere in every universe going to war with
each other and the funny thing about that is that
most of them are too lazy to care about something
like that like most of them don't even care what's
happening with other god's followers like oh okay
you know you do whatever you want to with your
people i'll do what i want to with my people
and most of the different pantheons police
themselves so if one of them gets out of
line like you have on moon knight ammit gets out
of line the other guy's like khonshu for example
try to do something about it you also have kang
the conqueror who's controlling the timeline or
at least up to a certain point before the king
multiverse war preventing things from going
really crazy so if there were gods that really
tried to step out of line kang would probably
try to do something to stop them all bets are
off though with the incursions in the lead up
to secret wars in the kang multiverse war it's all
connected if you spotted any other easter eggs in
this brand new scene that i didn't talk about in
the video just write them below in the comments
or any big questions i'll add them to my future
bonus videos my full obi-wan kenobi episode videos
will start posting next week so make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss that but everyone click here for my full
breakdown of the entire doctor strange 2 movie
every easter egg and click here for my full thor
love and thunder trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!